[Música]
a mí los insectos me apasionan por dos
cosas
por un lado me vuelve loca la diversidad
infinita de este tipo de pequeños seres
30 millones no de insectos de especies
nosotros decimos que los humanos
inventamos la rueda los escarabajos
peloteros trasladaban bolas de estiércol
muchísimo antes de que a nosotros se nos
ocurriera siquiera pararnos
los humanos inventamos el abono las
hormigas hacían compost bastante antes
de que lo hiciera cualquier ecologista
en su balcón y si por casualidad ustedes
pensaban que hemos inventado el aire
acondicionado están absolutamente
equivocados por supuesto que las
termitas lo han hecho primero y hasta
algunos que sirven como termómetros
y uno
se los presentó
los grillos
cuanto más clic se hacen mayores la
temperatura ambiente
obviamente varía según las especies pero
bastante preciso
y estos son solo algunos datos de cuatro
insectos imagínense todo esto
multiplicado por 30 millones
increíble
además los insectos
son riquísimos
y esa era la segunda cosa de las que les
quería contar
[Música]
a los 11 años me encontraba comiendo una
hamburguesa en una cadena de comida
rápida cuando un niño se me acerca y me
dice sabías que las hamburguesas están
hechas de insectos para bancar a los
insectos se pueden comer después me
enteré que lo de las hamburguesas era
todo un mito pero en su momento me quedé
muy entregada y me lo puse investigar y
efectivamente los insectos no solo se
pueden comer sino que además tienen
muchísimas muchísimas ventajas en
comparación con las producciones
agrícolas y ganaderas generan más
alimento en menos espacio y utilizando
menos recursos naturales
una vaca que pastorea necesita
aproximadamente una hectárea para
moverse mientras que los insectos no
necesitan más lugar del que ya ocupan
ahora si esa vaca que pastor era se le
da de comer 8 kilogramos de alimento
genera aproximadamente un kilogramo de
carne vacuna 8 en 1
mientras que si le doy esos mismos 8
kilogramos de alimento a los insectos me
generan 4 kilogramos 8 en 4 y encima los
insectos en general tienen más proteínas
cada 100 gramos que nuestra vaca por
darles un ejemplo los grillos tienen un
22% más de proteína
y como si eso no fuera suficiente la
producción ganadera es responsable del
37 por ciento del metano emitido por la
actividad humana que contribuye al
efecto invernadero y adivinen que los
insectos emiten entre 10 y 100 veces
menos que por ejemplo los cerdos
bueno bárbaro pero si los insectos son
tan geniales porque no están en las
góndolas de todos los supermercados
precisamente por las caras que pusieron
todas y todos ustedes cuando me comí
recién el grillo
nosotros acá no lo tenemos tan presente
pero en el mundo hoy hay 2 mil millones
de personas que comen insectos
habitualmente como latinoamericanos
hasta no hace tanto también lo hacíamos
nuestra dieta precolombina contaba con
una variedad importantísima de insectos
larvas de hormiga gusanos grillos etc
hasta que llegaron los españoles y
pusieron la misma cara que ustedes
probablemente cuando piensen en comer un
insecto se imaginen mordiendo una
cucaracha así o cortando con un cuchillo
una tarántula de este tamaño
pero no veis de tener un producto que se
está empezando a comercializar mucho es
la harina de insecto tiene todos los
beneficios que le mencioné antes sumado
a que ni te das cuenta que te estás
comiendo grillos en una porción de pan
entonces
qué hacemos para aprovechar más lo que
nos dan los insectos en 2017 con un
grupo de amigos fuimos a chile a la
primer cumbre latinoamericana de jóvenes
líderes en biotecnología ahí propusimos
una idea que creo que pueda ayudar
propusimos crear insectos para producir
alimentos con valor agregado en zonas
urbanas como solución a la falta de
espacio y al costo de los recursos
hicimos esto porque si las y los jóvenes
no derribamos estas barreras culturales
no lo va a hacer nadie de hecho ya lo
estamos haciendo con las cuestiones de
género y además en latinoamérica la
producción de alimentos es una parte
central de nuestra economía y no podemos
quedarnos atrás frente a estos cambios y
por esto no es necesario tener un galpón
gigante o hacer grandes inversiones yo
por ejemplo intento aportar mi granito
de arena en mi casa creando insectos
estudiando cómo prepararlos y cómo
transformarlos para que se haga más
fácil su consumo y si vemos a los
insectos más allá de nuestros prejuicios
y si lo vemos como termómetros como
grandes inventores pero también como
comida
la naturaleza nos provee una solución
rentable viable sustentable y encima
rica
aprovechémosla y tratemos de cambiar la
cara con la que vemos a los insectos
[Aplausos]
ahora
[Música]